بحدث اليوم الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
التقى بوتين لمده ثلاث ساعات في سوتشي
لمحاوله جد حل ازمه تصدير
الحبوب ومعي من اسطنبول عليها اسمر وصحفي
وكاتب سياسي علي اذا سمعنا الكثير وكنا
ننتظر اعلانا مثل ما يعني التصريحات
اردوغان قبل اللقاء كانت تدفع اكثر على
التفاعل مما هي عليه بعد اللقاء
نعم تحياتي لكم حقيقه تركيا استطاعت سابقا
تمديد معاهده الحبوب ولكن هذه المره هي
مختلفه عن سابقاتها لان الظروف متغيره حيث
نعلم ان حاليا المزارعين الروسي يخسرون
ملايين الدولارات يوميا بسبب عدم تصدير
الحبوب الروسيه والانتخابات التركيه ايضا
انتهت
وايضا اذا راقبنا المشهد والتسلسل الاحداث
بشكل كامل سوف نلاحظ ان التعنت الروسي
ازداد بعد قمه الناتو في ليتوانيا حيث ان
يبدو ان الروس قطعوا املهم من ان الغرب
سوف يتنازل لمطالب روسيا في تلك القمه حيث
كانت تلك القمه اكثرها دعم لاوكرانيا
وتزويد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه الذكيه وهذا
ايضا اضر قليلا بالعلاقات الروسيه التركيه
لذلك تم تاجيل اللقاء حوالي شهر من الان
ولكن الى الان الطيب اردوغان يحاول يحاول
يعني بكل العوده الى اتفاقيه الحبوب
والصحف الغربيه ايضا تعاون كثيرا على
الدوله الرئيس التركي ولكن انا اقول هنا
ان الرئيس التركي هو مجرد وسيط يعني تركيا
وسيط وتركيا لا تستطيع تلبيه مطالب روسيا
يجب على الدول الغربيه دعم تركيا للعوده
لهذه الاتفاقيه لانه يبدو ان بوتين وروسيا
الان يعني تقوم بالمثل بسياسه المثل مع
الدول الغربيه كما ان الدول الغربيه
تجاهلت المطالب الروسيه الان روسيا تتجاهل
العوده لاتفاق الحبوب وتركز فقط على تصدير
الحبوب الروسيه للدول الفقيره عبر وسيط
قطري جديد في هذا الملف طيب ولكن عندما
نتابع المؤتمر الصحفي نلاحظ ان هناك
محاوله من الجانب التركي
للترويض الدب الروسي عندما يحمل اوكرانيا
نوعا من المسؤوليه ويطالب بان تخفف من
مطالبها فيما يتعلق باتفاق الحبوب
نعم حاليا تركيا تقوم بالتوازن السياسي
بين الطرفين حيث راينا سابقا هي فكه اسر
بعض القاده الاوكرانيين وارسلتهم الى
اوكرانيا والان تقوم بدعم روسيا هذا النوع
من مسك العصا من المنتصف وهو ضروري جدا في
التفاوض السياسي لان بقاء تركيا في الوسط
اعتقد هو سيكون يعود بالخير على الطرفين
ولكن الان روسيا مصره على تحقيق مطالبها
التي تتمثل بعوده روسيا الى نظام سويفت
العالمي اعتقد ان روسيا تريد هذا الشيء
لتقويه اقتصادها ولهذا السبب ايضا الغرب
هو لا يريد عوده روسيا لنظام السويفت لذلك
من الممكن ان نشهد تعاون تركي روسي بنظام
جديد محلي روسي اسمه
هو بديل لسويفت واعتقد انه في هذا الشهر
يوجد العديد من القمم ان كانت في مجموعه
العشرين ان كانت
المتحده في نيويورك يعني الرئيس التركي
سوف يشارك بهذه القمم ومن الممكن ان يلتقي
ببايدن وبعض الدول الاوروبيه وبعدها اعتقد
سوف تتبلور الصوره بشكل اوضح لاني كما قلت
في السابق تركيا هي مجرد وسيط مطالب روسيا
التي تعتبرها محقه بالنسبه لها هي مطالب
كبيره لا تستطيع تركيا تنفيذ هذه المطالب
بل يجب على تركيا استشاره الجانب الغربي
وانا اعتقد ان اردنا العوده لملف لمعاهده
الحبوب يجب تقديم تنازلات لروسيا لان
روسيا تريد تصدير الحبوب الروسيه طيب
ساحاول ان افهم معك رويدا رويدا في شويه
تناقضات حسب التصريحات وحسب ما فهمنا من
هذه
التصريحات يعني ما عندما يقول اردوغان ان
تركيا لا تريد حلولا بديلا من جانب اخر
تزويد ست تول افريقيه
بالحبوب عبر تركيا وقطر الا يعتبر حلولا
بديله
لا طبعا هذه مبادره صغيره تشكلت بعد
التعنت الروسي حقيقه يعني هذا تصدير
الحبوب الى تركيا وتحويلها الى دقيق وقمح
وتحويلها للدول الافريقيه هو ليس بديل
دائم لمعاهده الحبوب ولكن هذه مناورات
روسيه وهذا هو عرض روسي وليس عرض تركي
بالمناسبه هكذا تحدثت الصحف الروسيه هذا
عرض روسي بعد ان قطع اماله الروس من
تنازلات من الغرب يحاول ان يلقى بدائل
اخرى والولايات المتحده واوكرانيا ايضا
يحاولون الان نقل هذه الحبوب عبر البر او
عبر وسائل اخرى لذلك منذ تعليق معاهده
الحبوب الجميع يحاول ان يرى خطط بديله
ولكن انا اعتقد هذه الخطط البديله لن تكون
دائما لن تكون نافعه لكل الاطراف لانها
اسمها بديله ان كانت نافعه لن تكن بديله
يجب ان تكون سياسيه يعني اساسيه لذلك
نعتقد هذه ليست هي مبادره صغيره جدا وليست
دائمه طيب المهم بالنسبه لاردوغان من خلال
ثلاث ساعات من المباحثات هو انه هو الذي
سيظل في صلب الموضوع ولفتره دائمه فيما
يتعلق باعتبارنا ويلعب دورا محوريا وهذا
ما يريده اردوغان
صحيح حقيقه لا يوجد بديل يعني روسيا لا
تريد ان تخسر تركيا لذلك اشركت تركيا في
هذه المبادره مع قطر والغرب ايضا لا يريد
ان يخسر تركيا لان تركيا هي تشكل الجسر
الواصل بين روسيا والغرب لذلك كلا الطرفين
لا يريدون خساره التركيه وتركيا يعني تركت
الباب مفتوح سوف تحاول مع الامم المتحده
اقناع بوتين وروسيا بالعوده لملف الحبوب
لمعاهده الحبوب وراينا يعني قبل ايام
الامم المتحده ارسلت مكتوبه واقتراحات
لسير يتضمن انه انشاء وربط فرع واحد من
البنك الزراعي الروسي بنظام السويت ولكن
هذا الطلب والمقترح رفضته روسيا سابقا
لذلك تركيا سوف تعول على هذا الجانب ايضا
لاننا كما قلنا تركيا هي مثل كل الدول
تحاول الاستفاده اقصى استفاده من هذه
الازمه
وتحويل وتركيا شاطره في تحويل الازمات الى
فرص وهي ايضا تريد حقيقه انهاء هذه الحرب
لاننا اذا راينا ان التمديد الحبوب هي
عارض اما الجذر هو الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه والمناوشات في البحر الاسود
ليست بمصلحه تركيا ابدا لذلك انا اعتقد ان
الرئيس التركي ايضا سوف يفتح ملف التهدئه
الاوضاع بين روسيا واوكرانيا من ناحيه
اخرى ولكن تركيا ستظل منطقه عبور لهذه
الحبوب
لانه لا يوجد بديل يعني هذا الشيء انفرد
على تركيا فرض الموقع الجيو السياسي
لتركيا
وقدر تركيا يعني يوجد مقوله باللغه
التركيه الجغرافيا هي قدر قدر تركيه ان
تكون الواصله بين الشرق والغرب بين اسيا
واوروبا فهي لا تستطيع ان تنعزل عن هذا
هذا المحيط يعني الجغرافي والجيوسياسي
يعني تركيين لم تتدخل منذ بدايه الامر
لاصبح في العالم غذائيه عالميه لذلك تركيا
تحاول ارضاء الطرفين انا اعتقد يوجد
العديد من المباحثات التي سوف تكون في هذا
الشهر الجاري يجب على الغرب يعني تقديم
بعض التنازلات لروسيا ويجب لروسيا ايضا
تقديم بعض التنازلات لان هذه الازمه نعم
من الممكن لها فوائد لتركيا ولكن ان
استمرت الحرب لن تستفيد تركيا بسبب
المناوشات الكبيره في البحر الاسود التي
تضر بالامن القومي التركي طيب علي ما هو
رصيد الثقه بين الرجلين اقصد بين الرئيسين
اردوغان وبوتين هل وصل الى سقف يسمح
بالقول ان بوتين يملك القدره على اقناع
انا انا اردوغان يملك القدره على اقناع
بوتين
نعم يعني انا اقول والصحف ايضا تقول الرجل
الوحيد الذي يستطيع اقناع الرئيس الروسي
هو اردوغان لماذا لان روسيا وتركيا بها
العديد من الملفات المشتركه ونقاط التقاطع
اذا لاحظنا اليوم صحيح انه تم التكلم
والاعلام تكلم فقط عن ازمه الحبوب ولكن
كان هناك يوجد فريق تركي كبير من
المسؤولين الرافعيين المستوى ذهبوا ما
اردوغان وتكلموا عن الطاقه روسيا تريد ان
تصنع تركيا
كمنطقه غاز او مركز غاز عالمي تريد ان
تكون مركز للحبوب وايضا يوجد يعني معاملات
في الطاقه النوويه ويوجد تبادل تجاري كبير
واستخدام الليره والروبل الروسي المحلي
ويوجد ايضا ارتفاع اعداد السياحه في تركيا
يعني بوتين هو مضطر ان يقبل بكلام اردوغان
لان اردوغان قد شخص غير قابل للاستبدال
بنسبه لبوتين طيب ولكن هو مثل ما قلت يلعب
دور الوسيط يلعب دور الوسيط مع الغرب ولكن
هل اردوغان قادر على ان يترجم مطالب الغرب
بشكل كفيل باقناع بوتين
طبعا يعني هذا هذا يتوقف على المشاورات
الذي من الممكن ان تكون في قمه العشرين
بين الرئيس التركي
يعني يوجد اختلاف في وجهات النظر يوجد
اختلاف نعم يعني يوجد اختلاف في الرؤى
واختلاف بالاولويات يعني لكل دوله تريد
اولوياتها والان يعني وزيره مساعده وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي بخصوص الاسلحه سوف تزور
تل ابيب وانقره خلال هذا الاسبوع اعتقد
ايضا سوف يتطرقون لهذا الموضوع كما قلت
يعني تركيا ليس لديها القرار الاخير ولكن
هي جسر وتقوم بمفاوضات بين اوكرانيا
وروسيا بين الغرب وبين الشرق والان يعني
ادراج العمل القطري العربي في هذا الملف
ايضا اعتقد انه سيكون ايجابي اي ان قطر
ايضا سوف تكون الوسيط وليس فقط تركيا علي
اسمر من اسطنبول شكرا جزيلا لك
فترتكم متواصله على
[موسيقى]